hello and welcome to this video playing
take me home then it's not a frequent
opponent nope Grandmaster Serbia yeah
alright some difficulties with those
flags okay um classical newsle here si
si si 5 is the most common and reliable
move it is played by most strong players
okay Jenna this is something that I
should know better than I actually do
but we'll see what happens now this is
5mm right here not quite sure I think
this is queenie to while Bishop f4 I
think we need to
yeah I only watched a video series of
young Gustafsson's once one time and it
I cannot really claim that i know this
line sufficiently well but yeah let's
see what happens Bishop f4 here I guess
where is there something better never
for looks very normal yeah white
structure is bad but what is goddess is
called excellent development and
pressure on the diagonal it's not easy
for black to develop his son is Bishop
from C aid okay something like 23 now
looks like a move just preventing Bishop
d7 or roop to be one who to be one s
also making lots of sense interesting
here 23 looks like a good move so after
b6 fc5 but ok I'm kind of making up
things here as I go along getting rid of
the double porn that way and still
maintain the activity ok just likes to
develop this way hmm ok roop d6 would be
interesting c6 is a move that's an
interesting move trying to keep that
pawn em why it's a debatable move route
28 will come but that's the only move
that from looks like Adele yeah it poses
real problems
okay interesting interesting i think
i'll go look to you for him if he takes
i can take with a pawn and it's not so
much the double power that I want to get
rid of it it said I want to look see one
to support my pollen c6 that it's in
half open file now yeah here d 5 comes
into consideration opening up against f7
because of the back rank I can actually
play the move hmm ok it's not not
necessary i also have only five that
it's also interesting Queenie five they
can probably hold that I can still go d
5 but i'm not sure if it is about that
if it helps you know that d 5 move 95
you can probably take and hold it with
Roxy aid okay I'm going for it can still
recapture that screen eat24 check if it
takes the takes the bishop
that's Oh
I wonder like Queen f4 all right start
it's not doing that much ok let's play a
non-committal move 114 yeah my time is
not good as usual
maybe a five assists a way to try to
play for a win but probably not take
screen b7 that's rookie seven and i'm
not getting anywhere time money i don't
think i can do much Queen f4 but she's
got rookie seven bra Harvard can he
can't Roger dry shuffle this on somehow
at the position is still pretty bad i
think just that I have no time and I
have no clear way forward um I don't see
don't see how to make headway here
you can probably stay here and shuffle I
can try let's say he goes here for
example I can do this but after the
capture couldn't be seven pieces that's
not not a problem and if I can do this
but this just leads to some
simplifications if I take it now if I
probably maybe I can approve earlier
next position is quite critical around
here I could have played d5 earlier but
rook seem honest I think it's okay
I don't see a clear way i have i have
put this pressure but something like
let's see 35 and can take and play king
of eight and i only get this far and now
i can do this and whatever but i'm not
i'm not winning this i have checked this
to to not lose but i don't see how to
how to win the position i always have to
watch for that pawn gym so I wasn't bad
at all I always had to head pressure
here but it never really felt like like
much is it a difference if i play t5
here I here can do this actually ok yeah
it looks kind of bad and that the green
has to has to play that the role of the
blockade here but it seems to be okay I
hear the engine wants to go rookie one
that's interesting check check it seems
to win so black and not take that's
probably more interesting the engine is
on +1 but i don't know if that if it
really leads to much because if you look
at its main line it's just shuffling
around Quincy to a 4 and so on basically
shuffling around and 12 it's very
obvious that why this calling the shots
but can you can you win them I doubt it
the way I plated it definitely wasn't
very very threatening yeah maybe draw as
a fair result to defend at this quite
well I guess
thanks for watching